What do you think about the Palestine
Israel situation at the moment?
What is there to laugh about? What is so
funny, man? I'll be I'll be honest, this
is a cowardice behavior.
Just imagine for a second that you give
£10 in donation and that £10 is used to
buy food or bricks or whatever to help
the people in Gaza. But then just
imagine this amazing deed that you want
to do, but we turn it into a
money-making machine. How?
The Waqf is exactly that. They take your
money and every single time the money
generated from that Waqf, that building,
is going to go to our Palestinian
brothers and sisters for the next 20,
30, 40, 50, 60, 100, 150 years. And this
will be a form of true Sadaqah Jariyah.
Click the link below and donate.
As-salamu alaykum wa rahmatullahi wa
barakatuh, brothers and sisters and dear
friends. Somebody sent me this video of
KSI.
Uh I think it was on Instagram or
YouTube, I can't remember. Um he's been
asked about the whole situation in Gaza,
the genocide that's taken place. It's
not a war, it's an outright genocide
that's happening. And this has been
going on for the past 75 years. We have
just got to see it via social media what
they've been doing for the past 75
years. Let's watch that video because
not only does he
speak about it, well, not the refuses to
speak about it, claims ignorance, and
also he
laughed about it. Let's Let's look at
it. What's Let's find out what's so
funny about it.
What do you think about the Palestine
Israel situation at the moment?
I
I honestly have no idea what's going on.
That's That is That is it. I have no
idea what's going on. I'm not getting
involved. It's way above me.
GET OUT.
PLEASE.
I DON'T KNOW. WELL, come on, man. We got
ours.
Less Less controversial questions,
please. So, guys, you heard that for
yourself. Let me translate in a few
words what he's basically trying to say.
He's He's He might be right that he
doesn't know. Let's go with the
argument's sake he doesn't want He
doesn't know. Yeah? He doesn't know
means in a nutshell he doesn't want to
know.
He doesn't want to look into it. He
doesn't want to research it. He doesn't
really care. Yeah? Imagine him laughing.
Imagine him laughing if they were asked
about the Holocaust that's going on.
Yes?
Imagine. Imagine they asked him about
whatever for that matter. Yes? About
Jews being massacred in America or some
kind of a mass shooting or whatever in a
synagogue. Would he be laughing? Do you
really think he'd be laughing? Do you
think his career would be still active
if he was to laugh about What do you
think about what's going on with the
shooting in America in a synagogue that
killed, let's say, 10 Jewish innocent
innocent people? Do you think he'd be
laughing? Yeah. No, he would not be
laughing. He's not going to laugh.
He does not want to know. Yes? So, two
options. Number one, yeah? Is he's
lying, he does know. Number two, he
doesn't want to know. He's just like,
"You know what? Yeah, I don't I don't
want to know about it, etc." Yeah?
You can clearly see. And in a nutshell
he's basically saying that, you know,
he's scared to get involved. And you
look at these individuals. They do
boxing fights, etc. This, that. And
that's That's what the prophet peace be
upon him said to us. He said, "Strong is
not the one who can wrestle another one
down. Strong is the one that can hold
his
anger.
Be patient. Yeah? So, you can see like
these guys You see like somebody being
tough, etc. Let me tell you something. I
don't believe anybody who's physically
strong is a tough guy or is, you know,
really really strong. Let me tell you
something. Wallahi, because he shows his
cowardice. This is a cowardice behavior
to see what is going on. For any matter
for that is like if I lived at the time
where King Leopold II, the scum dirty
bastard who killed 10 million Congolese
people. Yes? He would cut the hands of
little girls and throw it in front of
the father because he's not producing
enough, you know, in the field working
hard enough.
10 million. Does anybody speak about
this Holocaust? No. Nobody talks about
it at all. Yes? Not that I'm saying what
the Jews went through was any less. The
point is this not speaking about.
Imagine me speaking about it. And he
comes from black I don't know where he's
from exactly, yeah?
He's He's He's an African himself. Yes?
What the Congolese, yes, 10 million of
them massacred. Imagine somebody asking
me and saying, "What do you think about
what King Leopold II is doing in Congo?"
So, I would
"You know how Come on, guys. Stop asking
me some more controversial question.
What is there to laugh about? What is so
funny, man? I'll be I'll be honest, this
is a cowardice behavior." Yes? I don't
give a damn what kind of a box do you
want? I don't give a damn about that
matter. Okay? All right. The fact that
you don't want to talk and let me tell
you something. Allah tells us in the
Quran Allah told you this. Yeah?
Wallahi, the fact that you can't speak.
Why? You're going to lose wealth, money?
What are you scared of? Why can't you
talk about? You're ignorant about it?
The whole world knows. There's a
billions of posts. Billions. There was
study done about 103 billion posts
compared to
couple of billion to Israeli posts.
Okay? Showing you what is going on in
the world. Yes, you don't know? You know
very well. Yes, you know very well.
You're probably being told, you know,
your prime sales. Yeah, but by the way,
I believe people should not even buy
that. Should boycott that. Shouldn't
even buy that. The All the sales might
be affected. Oh, my manager said to me
not to talk about it. This is what you
talk about. And what do we What are we
told as Muslims in the Quran by Allah
Subhana Wa Ta'ala? Allah says, "All you
who believe, be persistently standing
firm in justice. Not towards a Muslim,
towards non-Muslim, anyone for that
matter. Justice is justice. Witness for
Allah, even if it be against yourself or
parents or relatives." Meaning, "If my
own blood brother wrongs somebody, I
will tell my brother, you are wrong.
They are right. If it's my father, if
it's my mother, if it's my daughter."
The prophet peace be upon him said, "If
Fatima was to steal, the punishment of
amputating the hand will be applied to
her." Because this is what we look at.
And what does Allah say next? "Whether
one is rich or poor, Allah is more
worthy of both. So, follow not personal
inclinations lest you be lest you not be
just. And if you distort your testimony
or refuse to give it, then indeed Allah
is ever Allah is ever know of what you
do and he is aware." So, you did not
have the guts. You are somebody who will
go in the ring and do 10 rounds and this
cardio and that and blah blah blah.
You didn't even have the balls. You
didn't even have the guts
to come and say, "You know what? What is
happening is an absolute genocide. It's
a massacre of innocent men, women, and
children." You will go down in history,
KSI,
as an intellectual coward.
You are I'm so sorry. You are an
intellectual coward. You have a massive
platform and you could have done that,
but no.
Your riches and your wealth You think is
going to save you and you're invincible.
Oh, no, you're not. That is the reason
why we believe in the day of judgment.
Because, you know why? Because the judge
of the all judges, the God Almighty, he
is the one that's going to judge and
he's going to be just. And you are going
to be remembered as what? Somebody who
did not even have a backbone to come out
and say it. So, shame on you. And guess
what? We don't really care about your
opinion. I don't really give a damn
about KSI's opinion or like whatever for
that matter. We don't need that. It just
tells us so much about who you are and
what you prioritize. And Muslims, you
follow KSI. You're going to carry on
following him after this? You're not
going to call him up for this? Shame on
you. You are You guys are as coward as
he is. I will call him out. And you can
call it
fame, views, whatever you like. I don't
give a damn.
I've called out Muslim influencers as
well. So, that's all I'm going to say,
KSI. Shame on you for laughing and
giggling on a matter where babies,
daughters, sons are being massacred,
body parts blown into pieces.
And what are you going to do? You'd
rather be in your comfy sofa at home.
But don't worry. Allah is the most just.
I ask Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala to guide
you
to Islam. That Allah can in Islam cuz
let me tell you something, you are so in
damn in need of Islam because you are so
wrapped up in the worldly affairs. Islam
will set you free with all these
shackles that you have of your master
behind you thinking that you're in
control. Islam will save you from that.
Islam will show you what true justice is
and to speak out against it like the
prophet peace be upon him said and I'll
end on that.
If you see evil, try to stop it with
your hands. And if you cannot stop it
with your hands, at least speak about
it, against it.
And even if you can't do it, hate it in
your heart. Neither do you do anything
with your hands, maybe you can't.
Neither do you speak out about it when
you can.
Number three, you don't even hate it in
your heart. You are laughing about it.
Shame on you and the laugh is on you.
Brothers and sisters, we are trying to
build a Waqf inshallah in Wales to buy a
building that will generate funds to
help our Palestinian brothers and
sisters, inshallah. Please check that
link in the description box below and
donate generously and invest in the
hereafter. As-salamu alaykum wa
rahmatullahi wa barakatuh.